okay let's let's cover this before we
delve into more I had a number of people
in my audience ask about Joe Rogan
because apparently there's something
going on with you and Joe Rogan so can
you give a bit of a background about
what that's about and what happened sure
something like seven years ago I went on
the Joe Rogan show three times
and in fact I'll post something on
Instagram because you can't see it Joe
pulled it off of Spotify he's been
trying to hide this and
Bulletproof Coffee changes brain for the
better I mean he's worn the bulletproof
t-shirt on on there and was just a huge
fan and I uh and he's like damn oh my
goodness grass-fed beef this is so
important I I love all this but then one
of his buddies decided to try to steal
both the name bulletproof as well as uh
my ideas and one of the companies he
owns decided to try to steal and copy my
products and the day they made that
decision he made up some stuff around uh
around me as well as some fake tests
that have never existed as far as I can
tell saying that my coffee was moldy
because I've spent way more than a
hundred thousand dollars on lab tests
over the years the Bulletproof Coffee
that I created is lab tested to the
highest possible standards
um but he basically tried to discredit
me for quite a while it looks like it
was partly financially motivated and
partly probably one of his buddies
manipulating him and so I I learned a
lot about bullying and what bullies do
when they grow up uh it was it was rough
because I'm like I'm helping people I'm
I'm motivated by not letting people get
to 300 pounds like I did and just not
have brain fog and I know the kind of
suffering out there and it went from
Dave thanks for all of your advice to
you know you're a charlatan snake oil
salesman because like there's about 20
000 trolls the the death squad guys and
literally they stick them on me so all
of a sudden my social media just went
all to Hell overnight I'm like wow
this is kind of freaking me out and I
didn't really know how to take it so I
did some of the weird personal
development stuff that I do and I just
realized after a little while every time
Joe says something bad about me I'm
selling more coffee
even though like it kind of hurts and I
just realized I didn't do anything wrong
I I did everything at the highest
Integrity uh and what's cool is uh now
that Joe's pulled those things down
there's fair use exemptions so I put
together a compilation of all the things
Joe's said and like you can try and reel
it back by deleting it but bottom line
is I'm pretty sure that there's a reason
the company is that Joe owns are
starting to sell MCT oil and trying to
copy the coffee they just couldn't do
the mold free thing so we tried to say
it wasn't real and I would challenge
anyone who thinks it's not real to just
read what I write
damn okay
that's spicy Joe thank you brother I
appreciate all the sales I appreciate
you I appreciate all the stuff you're
doing in the world and uh I don't feel
bad for not getting high before I was
interviewed on your show because I would
have sounded like a total idiot
[Music]